>>> ARE YOU FEELING TIRED AND
WORN DOWN?
SICK OF THE ENDLESS GRIND AT
WORK?
EXHAUSTED BY YOUR FAMILY,
DESPERATE FOR SOME PEACE AND
QUIET.
>> DANIEL, YOUR KIDS WANT YOU!
>> THEN ASK YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT
COVID.
AS SOON AS GETTING COVID, YOU'RE
GUARANTEED A FIVE AND SOMETIMES
EVEN TEN-DAY VACATION FROM ALL
OF LIFE'S PROBLEMS.
>> I NEEDED A BREAK, SO MY
DOCTOR SUGGESTED I GET COVID,
AND IT WAS THE GREATEST WEEK OF
MY LIFE.
ALL I WANTED TO DO WAS WATCH THE
NETFLIX I WANTED TO WATCH, AND I
WAS FINALLY ABLE TO THANKS TO
COVID.
>> AT FIRST I WAS WORRIED ABOUT
GETTING COVID, BUT MY DOCTOR
ENSURED ME IT WAS OKAY.
>> SIDE EFFECTS OF COVID INCLUDE
HAVING COVID, WHICH IS STILL
KIND OF BAD, BUT DOESN'T IT FEEL
DIFFERENT NOW?
>> I DEFINITELY GOT SICK.
I ALSO GOT PAID FOR TEN DAYS TO
NEVER LEAVE THE BLANKET.
PLUS I GOT TO TELL PEOPLE ABOUT
IT AT WORK.
IT WAS LIKE I HAD A BAD COLD FOR
THREE DAYS.
>> OF COURSE I HAD TO ISOLATE
FROM MY KIDS BECAUSE I DIDN'T
WANT TO GET THEM SICK.
>> WHAT DO THEY EAT?
>> I GAVE IT 14 DAYS TO BE EXTRA
SAFE.
>> FOR AN EXTRA FEE, WE'LL KNOCK
OUT THE WI-FI NEAR YOUR HOUSE SO
YOU CAN'T DO ANY ZOOM.
>> OH, WELL, TOO BAD.
>> COVID IS THE PERFECT WAY TO
GET OUT OF JURY DUTY, NEIGHBOR'S
ADULT BAPTISM, AND HUSBAND'S
MURDER TRIAL.
AT THIS POINT, COVID IS A
TEN-DAY CRUISE, WHICH IS ALSO A
GREAT WAY TO GET IT.
>> COVID ISN'T FOR ANYONE.
THAT'S WHY THERE'S THE NEW
ALWAYS POSITIVE COVID TEST THAT
COME WITH TWO PINK LINES ALREADY
DRAWN.
>> AGAIN?
>> YOU JUST HAD IT A WEEK AGO.
PLEASE DON'T DO THIS TO ME.
>> BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE ONLY
WAY TO GET MENTALLY HEALTHY IS
TO GET PHYSICALLY SICK.
>> SURE.
THERE MIGHT BE LONG-TERM MEMORY
PROBLEMS, BUT THAT MIGHT BE
AMAZING BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
I WANT TO FORGET.
>> MY BRAIN IS ALREADY REALLY
BAD.
BUT IF I DON'T HAVE TO TALK TO
PEOPLE IN A WEEK, I'LL TAKE THAT
DEAL IN A HORSE BEAT.
>> YOU MEAN HEART BEAT.
>> EITHER WAY, THANKS COVID.
>> THANKS, COVID.
>> I THINK I'LL GET COVID AGAIN.
TODAY.
>> COVID, GO AHEAD.
YOU DESERVE A BREAK.
[ APPLAUSE ]